this video is made possible by blinkist
the first hundred people to go to
blinkist.com forward slash visualpolitik
you're going to get unlimited access for
one week to try it out you'll also get
25 percent off if you want the full
membership
more about that later but for now let's
get on with it shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
dubai is a very different place from any
other place in the persian gulf its
economy isn't based on oil on natural
gas
or any other raw material but instead
mainly on tourism
transport trade and finance but despite
not being rich in natural resources in
the last four decades dubai became
one of the most prosperous cities in
history
[Music]
since the first towers began to emerge
in the desert this city's growth has
been
non-stop the tallest building in the
world the largest shopping mall the
largest airport the most luxurious hotel
you can find everything here and we
could say that this city
is made by and for money everything
absolutely everything
in this enclave is shaped by the money
flowing
into and out of it however 2018 hasn't
exactly been the emirates happiest
year
[Music]
in the last 12 months the dubai stock
market has plummeted by almost
25 new business licenses have decreased
and for the first time ever
employment has also fallen look we have
to
we have to plan for the worst
today more and more analysts are
wondering whether dubai is about to
undergo
a huge crisis and this precisely is the
main question today and that
is dubai losing its shine well listen up
signs and shadows
while much of the arab world is facing a
great deal of chaos economic crises
political crises
violence dubai is very busy developing
3d printers theme parks air taxi
services and
even working to send a probe to mars
within just three years
but as i was saying 2018 hasn't been a
very good year look even
though more than 90 percent of dubai's
population is foreign schools for
expatriates are closing or losing
students and moving companies are
showing
one clear trend more people are leaving
than arriving
and although the construction pace is
still in full swing it's becoming
increasingly clear that many of these
new buildings are half empty
[Music]
apartments offices hotels shopping
centers obtaining official statistics
is not easy but what happens when
there's more supply than there is demand
well prices drop and that's exactly what
is happening
[Music]
and not only that imar properties stocks
the company that built the burj khalifa
and those of lots of other large
developers listed on the dubai stock
exchange have suffered a collapse of
almost
40 per cent in the last year alone
want more well dxb entertainment's the
company that owns most of the theme
parks that have opened in dubai in
recent years such as legoland dubai
motiongate and bollywood park is
negotiating with banks to restructure
more than 1
billion in debt simply because the
number of visitors is much
lower than expected so you can probably
see now that it's not exactly time to
celebrate and so the question we can now
ask ourselves here on visualpolitik is
well
what the is happening we're going to ask
why is dubai
facing this possible crisis and is this
the end of the emirate that has broken
every middle eastern mold well let's see
[Music]
the storm
dubai is facing a completely new
scenario in this case the origin of the
problem may
lie far beyond its ruler's competence
allow me to explain dubai is perhaps the
most famous emirate
in the united arab emirates but it's abu
dhabi that has the oil the money and the
power
in fact even though sheikh muhammad bin
rashid governs dubai it's this man here
muhammad bin zayed the crown prince of
abu dhabi who de facto rules
all the united arab emirates
well the key to dubai's huge success was
becoming something like the
switzerland of the middle east the
freest space the most legally secure
and the most open to the rest of the
planet and of course yes they
absolutely had low taxes however now
some of these things
are starting to be questioned
in the last two to three years the
united arab emirates government has
adopted a very active foreign policy
prince muhammad bin zayed has completely
aligned himself with
saudi prince muhammad bin salman
specifically on two fronts
qatar and iran check this out
on the one hand both countries have led
the blockade against qatar a country
that has very close ties with dubai
in fact many international companies
settled in dubai and their executives
traveled to and from
doha and jebe dubai's great port was
also qatar's most important supply
center
now well that's all over with the
blockade the uae ordered all qatari
citizens to leave the country most
flights were suspended and freight
traffic was interrupted
now qatar is directly provisioned by or
through
amman but no longer through jabel ali
[Music]
with the blockade dubai has lost a very
important commercial partner in addition
to all of this many companies and
investors have noticed that legal
security and maneuverability weren't as
strong as they previously thought
because
as you can see dubai ultimately depends
on decisions made in abu dhabi but
that's
not all
[Music]
dubai also has very important relations
with iran in fact thanks to its
proximity dubai became something of an
escape route a place for many iranian
leaders and entrepreneurs to stay for a
few days
have some fun and spend some money and
not only that every year their
commercial business transactions with
iran surpassed
20 billion but now because of u.s
sanctions and the growing diplomatic
conflict between riyad and tehran this
trade is shrinking by
leaps and bounds the ships that used to
send goods every week
now go once a month
in other words in just over a year dubai
has lost two of its largest trading
partners due to decisions made in abu
dhabi
and do you think that's all well it's
absolutely not
as dubai became sort of a playground and
second safe zone for iranians the same
thing happened with saudi citizens and
businessmen
of course given all the restrictions
that saudi arabia has for the saudis
dubai
is an oasis of freedom and safety well
when the saudi prince mohammed bin
salman unleashed his war against
corruption
or a move to consolidate his power
rather and locked up or kidnapped dozens
of saudi businessmen and senior
officials the arab emirates central bank
demanded all banks operating in the
country to give riyadh all the
information they had on the detainees
accounts
and they delivered all this information
even when they hadn't been charged
information
of course riad used to get the money
from all those businessmen who then had
to buy their freedom
with their checkbooks that way the saudi
businessman who thought that dubai was
the true switzerland of the middle east
realized that this wasn't really the
case yes
in dubai there's legal security and your
savings are safe but not the information
with which the autocratic saudi
government can extort you
[Music]
so you're probably beginning to see
where the problem is well due to these
reasons and others the dubai financial
industry is also
suffering but oh no we haven't yet
reached the end of this list the
headaches they don't
simply stop here
[Music]
the dropping oil prices in recent years
have affected the purchasing power of
many of the people who spend their money
in dubai a lower oil price means less
income and that as we've seen her in
visualpolitik has meant that some
countries like saudi arabia have to make
many many cuts
and finally there's another factor that
depends on dubai itself in a certain way
the city runs the risk of becoming a
victim
of its own success and yes you heard
that right
[Music]
thanks to dubai's huge success its
prices have skyrocketed especially when
it comes to real estate and yeah dubai
does have very low taxes but the state
gets many resources through building
licenses
which hasn't helped either if to all of
this we add the fact that many middle
eastern countries to reduce their
dependence on oil have launched plans to
copy this city by giving many advantages
to their investors the result is that
dubai has lost its appeal to
international
companies in recent years anyway as you
now see
these are the roots of the problem abu
dhabi qatar iran
and the cost of its own success they've
all decreased this emirate city's
attractive oasis status but what many of
you
might be wondering is well what now so
listen up
[Music]
perspectives
even though its economy is expected to
grow by just over two percent in 2019 as
you can see dubai
isn't going through the best of times
but hold on a second because this
doesn't mean everything's lost
not at all in spite of everything this
city emirate continues to be an oasis in
the desert and its government seems to
have a clear idea
of the keys to its success therefore
what sheikh muhammad bin rashid's
government is doing now is trying to
make dubai's economy even more
competitive with its neighbors
to do so they're making it easier to
obtain a visa they're ensuring that
expatriates who lose their jobs have an
easier time
staying and they're decreasing the
obstacles of foreign business owners
outside of the special economic zones
in other words they want to connect
dubai even more with the rest of the
world
in fact local authorities have high
hopes for the arrival of chinese
investors
this is a market cycle that we have to
accept the government is doing what it
did
in past slumps sitting down with
business to figure out solutions
fahad al-gargawi head of the investment
agency
dubai fbi when the upturn
does arrive dubai's companies will
emerge leaner and more competitive
katija hak head of regional research at
local lender emirates nbd
folks this is what is happening in this
city-state that has had such a positive
impact
on the middle east yes in dubai a lot of
unfortunate things
may be reported but opening up to the
world has been a breath of fresh air for
one of the most hostile areas on the
planet in terms of human rights
in dubai not only can you drink alcohol
eat pork and
pray at a catholic church now you can
even go to a synagogue and
eat kosher food yeah again you really
did hear that right
as the gulf warms up to israel a
synagogue grows in dubai
anyway only the future will be able to
tell if this city-state's frenetic
growth pace will continue or if instead
dubai is doomed
to suffer a huge crisis and lose its
shine so far the party continues
a dubai company will build the largest
sports shopping center
in the world so i hope you enjoyed that
video and as i said at the beginning
this one was made possible by blinkist
now do you manage to read
all the books you want you manage to get
all of that knowledge in your head
probably not right i mean everyone seems
busier than ever it seems like there's
hardly time to spend learning it's much
easier just to click on that other
tempting video
over there on the right about some
nonsense or other now you might not
think that you have a ton of time
to read but the good news is that even
if you don't you can use blinkist
blinkist is an app that takes the best
insights and need to know information
from
thousands of non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15 minutes which you
can either read or listen to they've got
a huge
library and 8 million users
i think i'm actually probably the ideal
blinkist customer i spend a lot of time
working and far less time learning
than i should and i often plug into the
audio versions and listen to them while
i'm like unloading the dishwasher and
boring tasks like that listen they've
got tons of popular titles like the four
hour work week from tim ferriss but
they've also got stuff you guys probably
really be into lots of political stuff
and you know like i often say on this
channel
let's take a look back at the history
they've got books condensed like the
silk roads by peter
frankipan the first hundred people to go
to blinkist.com forward slash
visualpolitik are going to get unlimited
access for one week to try it out you'll
also get 25
off if you want the full membership move
fast grab one of those now and get
started in one of those political
history books the seven day trial is
completely free you can cancel it at any
time
during that trial if you're not into it
but you will be
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]
you